and unless kyrie just be a scorer who
doesn't want to just go out there and
score all the time
will he score again yes he will
back-to-back trees for kyrie irving such
a quick trigger
he also has a very offensive mindset so
he's one of those guys that you have to
be on guard with him at all times
[Music]
yeah this is where he excels this
one-on-one permitto allowing the second
most points per game in the nba only
washington allows more
james harden the beard takes it strong
to the basket
the nets get a second chance
harden sizing up heal bottom
james harden on fire
kings have not missed a free throw
and the jump shot goes seven to shoot
heart full isolation harden
in his bag lee a three
get into a set out of the timeout
hard jeff green oh
that's a man's jam uncle
jeff hard to the hole look at jeff green
pop but his ability to roll and finish
tapped out volleyball style and the nets
will control it
irving off balance cans it from long
range
it and kyrie look at this just taking
he's going to the side just getting more
space
and then once he has it he knows when
he's feeling it
yeah bear down go cats
kyrie irving a downtown hit
and luke we know what happened a couple
of years ago when the nets made the
furious comeback
irving a silencer